[Music]
all right it is YouTube week here on the
Rubin report and I am with that guy T
also known as T also known as to lead
also known as anything else and I think
that's about it that's about it
you are a atheist libertarian youtuber
you got one or two more adjectives I
watched your channel trailer you had a
few more adjectives for yourself yeah
atheist libertarian youtuber
anarcho-capitalist [ __ ] sometimes
you know what depends you know now
probably sits head not not white male
but sis head and male should learn
nonetheless yeah now according to my
notes here you are black is that correct
I think so think so
okay just what a good you know I'm just
looking at the notes here alright people
bleh bud I didn't buy em yeah yeah well
because I know people love labels and I
don't want to hide anything from the
audience before you give your views
because you obviously represent everyone
right exactly I think for the entire
black community me and vitalize Marian
negotiations right now they're trying to
get me a Top Gun d-brane but you know
soon enough
yeah alright so I'm psyched to have you
on because I do just great you're clear
to the point funny I love what you're
doing so let's go let's just knock out
the atheist stuff first cuz I don't
think that's really your focus but you
you talk about it a bit
when did you kind of come around to
realizing that you're an atheist um
probably I'd say around like when I was
like 17 prior to that I was I mean
throughout my entire life I never really
been religious so I never really had
that religious awakening road like oh oh
this is [ __ ] I always kind of
figured you know like that a mini story
like come on wait and once I figure out
what incest was I like so am I am I
missing some chromosomes oh yeah that
never was really fully religious um you
know going forward I became a deist for
a short time and I'm
probably gonna do a video on that pretty
soon is explaining why I felt the need
that had to believe in some God I felt
that was somehow better than just
believing in any God and from there I
just figured you know what I don't
really know any guy that I do believe in
um if there is one awesome you know
maybe he could help me out but if it's
not whatever I don't have any evidence
for it being one or for the really not
being on it either I don't have any
evidence for its existence whatsoever so
I figure hey I'm an atheist
yeah I mean that's pretty much what I
say show me some evidence and we can we
can have that conversation yet nobody
nobody seems to have any I don't know
b.o.b b.o.b has some pretty pretty big
stats on the earth being flat so it's
just something out there Yeah right
exactly
alright so that I think that's enough on
atheism we got the point you you like
evidence and evidence I think is partly
what led you to libertarianism and I
think this is really your your kind of
core thing you're a libertarian through
and through fair to say yeah that's
pretty fair to say okay so for the
people that have no idea even though
I've been trying to talk about classic
liberalism here and libertarianism what
is a libertarian okay so this is the
moment I've been waiting for yet going
I'm not going to get on into the you
know be as physically conservative
conservative socially liberal you know
mass mass consumption version of
libertarianism I think your audience and
this is a compliment I think they're
smart enough to really know what
libertarianism is so really quickly want
to pull it up because they lived a
picture on Instagram that had a
definition of it I couldn't memorize it
but it was just so perfectly summarized
like this you did homework I did not
tell you any of the questions in advance
this is very impressive listen man I'm
representing I'm representing
libertarianism on your show I have to
have to be pretty it's a pretty big deal
alright so libertarianism is basically
centered around maybe people man I like
this but since around the principles of
non-aggression and property rights and
this is a definition that I saw on
Instagram that just summarized it
perfectly basically is the idea that
every individual has the right
- life liberty and just li acquired
property and the freedom to pursue their
own self-interest we have coercion so
long as in doing so they don't inflict
with others individual rights I think
that's pretty pretty straightforward so
that doesn't that sound pretty damn good
to you cuz that sounds pretty damn good
to me it does you know I mean I mean I
don't know anyone who doesn't want to
pursue their own self injurers I don't
know anyone who thinks you know I want
to do this thing but I really wish there
was some other buzzkill out there who
would force the government to stop me
from doing what I want to do and of
course there are some crazy people who
may want to go out and shoot up high
schools or you know dump dump you know
nuclear waste into you know rivers and
whatnot but we have precautions for
those type of things those type of
things do infringe on others individual
rights so we're not gonna go that far
and allowing freedom but pretty much
everything else as long as you're not
actually hurting anyone or preventing
anyone else from doing what they want to
do is open season you should be able to
do what you want yeah so I'm with you on
that but is that the inherent catch-22
of libertarianism and why when you watch
the libertarian I think me and you were
probably the only two people on earth
that watch the libertarian debate on on
Fox Business or actually wait did you
not watch it I tweeted at you during it
and I think maybe you said you didn't
watch it I watch didn't watch the first
one the second one I watched things like
the last last 30 minutes of it buddy I
missed the first one I caught up on it
afterwards the post show but not live
yet so there's a point of being very few
people watch it even at the libertarian
convention I suppose the catch-22 with
libertarians is you're saying do what
you want and when you say that to people
you have these real anarchists who want
no government no regulation no driver's
licenses no no control whatsoever versus
I think what you describe or as you know
the the easy way to understand it which
is the fiscally conservative socially
liberal stuff that's I kind of fit into
that more easily understandable category
but is it hard to unify people is that
the libertarians problem it's hard to
unify people under the guise of
do what's right for you yeah it's really
our unified libertarians and I've seen
the algae used before organizing
libertarian is like herding cats so you
know we're it's such an individualist
philosophy that you can't really
collectivize it especially in like a
political party but even in terms of
just like a you know just a just like a
cohesive group in a lot of libertarians
you know range from anarcho-capitalist
which identify as big let me lay out
what that is for people that don't know
another capitalist is uh pretty much
someone who believes in the
non-aggression principle of someone who
believes that pretty much what I
explained but to the fullest degree so
you know that means we want we don't
want any coercion of things like court
systems we don't want any coercion
involved with things like you know
building infrastructure or providing
charity or welfare we believe I'm going
to say this it's gonna read your
comments bring axes and is theft it is
and you know a lot of other things you
know basically a completely voluntary
approach to libertarianism you know big
libertarianism is kind of like you know
we we we believe in really limited
government we still need government free
things like the fence roads and all that
and our pro-capitalist believe that that
should be privatized and then you have a
grist and you know volunteers then you
know the new consensual ism and
classical liberals I would consider a
branch of libertarianism make more so to
the left but still their market and our
kiss then it goes really really far all
these different ideological labels but
pretty much you know and I say this too
as long as you're willing to respect the
core foundation of libertarianism we can
argue about the details going forward we
can argue about how far we want to go
but let's just get some simple things
done by let's end the drug war we all
agree that's a bad thing
let's try to legalize you know um know
markets that are that are criminalized
right now you know like prostitution you
know can we all agree that women have
the right to sell their own body as they
see fit and we go further down you know
we we get you know you want to
completely abolish of taxes you know I
think the IRS could probably go away
yeah but we can talk about that later
right now let's just at least this is at
least agree that freedom should be
something that we should all be pursuing
to achieve or enhance and we should try
to drift more so way that was about to
say slowly but really more quickly away
from authoritarianism yeah so I'm fully
on board that and I I've been pushing
this idea over the individual instead of
the collective you you did a great video
on that by the way talking about the
individual and why people you should
care about the individual as ayaan Hirsi
Ali says the ultimate minority is the
individual so we have to be aware of the
individual what do you think
libertarians can do cuz I don't hear
your 22 is that right yes great
you don't hear many 22 year old
libertarians like it seems old-school to
see your Liberty that seems old even
though I do think it's starting to
bubble up now because our political
system is so screwed
but it seems like it's not cool to be a
libertarian it's cool to be a socialist
somehow yeah and even then it's not even
really cool to be a socialist that much
anymore I mean aside from people who
just really don't understand economics
and just actually believe that socialism
will work you know socialism is dying
off you know we we've had no the left
democrats promote a lot of left-leaning
socialist policies we're seeing
socialism fail and other countries in
real time such as venezuela and you know
that Marxism and communism you know
there's still the you know the trinity
and our kids who are you know saying
we're gonna see the mean the means of
production and kill the capitalist class
bring it on
you know for those but but yeah you know
I don't think I don't think socialism is
still that cool but I think it still
appeals to a lot of people especially in
times where you have you know like the
student loan debt bubble you know you
have increased um yeah just basically a
lot of economic problems like economic
hardships you know income inequality
which I don't really think is a
necessarily a bad thing but you have a
lot of crony capitalism involved with it
you have a lot of people feeling
disparage and they're like you know hey
you know that I feel like I'm not
I'm good I feel like I'm not getting
ahead and you have these politicians
come in and say hey I can give you free
stuff from the government and that's
really appealing to young people but I
think I'm saying a lot of people also
shift tours so there's a lot of young
people shifting towards libertarianism a
lot of people are adopting principles of
freedom and also even I'm not I'm not
giving them a shout out here but the
alright is gaining a lot of traction too
with Trump and people going you know way
from neo stablishment conservatism and
going towards more libertarian whenever
libertarian but like classical
constitutionalist Tea Party type
conservatism and I think that's somewhat
beneficial left I mean getting away from
the authoritarian nature of the left
which left you know it's usually been
that the left is economically
authoritarian and the right is socially
authoritarian the all right is less
socially authoritarian I would say but
it's also much less economically
authoritarian I think as long as you're
the left it may become more social
thermo smore socially libertarian here
and there but it never really becomes
more socially economically libertarian
it's always economically authoritarian
there always want to control your
wallets the argument of controlling
markets always going to control you know
basically anything any consensual
transaction that involves
money that involves profit and I think
that's a really bad thing not only for
the individual but for society as a
whole and I think a lot of people are
starting to realize that and shift away
from it yeah so it sounded in there
somehow that you almost you almost were
given some props - all right I don't
think you were fully backing the alright
but I think a lot of people when they
would hear you say that well first of
how would you define alright for people
that aren't in the bubble of this online
world that were in what would you say is
the all right all right I've always
defined as 60% disgruntled conservatives
disgruntle Republicans maybe 30% um this
trolls and you know 4chan 4chan users
10% neo-nazis so that would say that
probably sums up all right pretty good
right so that's where I was gonna go
with that because it's it seems funny
I'm sure a certain amount of people
watching this people that like you were
gonna go wait a minute he just kind of
gave a tip of the hat to the alright but
all right
is also thought of there there is a
definite true xenophobic element to that
that's probably not big on black people
and not big on Jews and atheists and
some other people as well
but I guess every movement has has their
bad apples exactly I mean you know
anytime anytime I personally going out
right circles you'll always see the
occasional din do you know you always
see the occasional no sin in profanity
word I'll say it later when I right now
and you know you always you always see
these you know bigoted some of them are
edge lower some of them are actually
just hateful people but even even in
their hateful rhetoric they're not
really actively advocating for
government to you know to you know enact
harm or violence against me they're not
actually advocating to control my life
or to exile me or to you know basically
have any sort of authoritarian influence
over me they're just being very critical
of you know would that be you know um
other races IQ levels or things like
that but yeah you could be the pro kleh
as you want you know I'm not I'm not you
know easily triggered I can have a
conversation about anything so it really
doesn't bother me I'm gonna figure out a
way to trigger you during this if
there's a way but I mean look I'm the
same way on that it's like people always
say well how do you deal with all of
them and they're saying all this [ __ ]
and it's like oh they're so scary by
their computers sending memes it's like
all right exactly they said some [ __ ]
what do you want me to do exactly
I'll say it now [ __ ] no it doesn't hurt
I don't care it's just words it's just
conversations I think people people are
really really easily offended now and
that's something I've always despised
not even in terms of just political
correctness in terms of everyday life
people get easily offended by the most
banal things where you can just really
brush it off
and you know if you want really if you
really want to display strip if you
really want to display you know that
you're above these people then do so by
you know combating their ideas like you
always suggest you know do so by like
standing your ground you know saying you
you believe this I believe this I want
to continue to hold my beliefs I'm not
going to run away to a safe space I'm
not going to try to prevent you from
speaking on my campus or anything like
that I'm gonna try to get you fired
because I disagree with you we just
disagree and I think is pretty okay to
just leave it at that
so all this victim culture stuff which
you're hitting on which I get it too
it's like people want to be professional
victims all the time and if you say
something to them then they're oppressed
and then they can oppress someone else
because they've been oppressed it's
actually completely the reverse of the
type of libertarianism you're for right
because if you're for the individual
you're basically saying your life is
your responsibility so there's there's
actual interesting sort of economic
component to this victim culture stuff
you're saying go get yours I have no
need to be a victim right exactly I
don't see any value in it and you know I
don't I don't
you know if someone wants to be a victim
you know go right ahead you know I'm not
gonna stop you from being a victim but
you know I'm not gonna actively you know
condone I'm not going to actively
subsidize your victimhood I'm not going
to you know pay because I pay you money
or you know give you legitimacy just
because you feel like you're oppressed
or you feel like you know society owes
you something you know you're not really
owed anything you know what that being
and this is something I get our my lower
body always when he comes on said the
only people who are truly all something
is in America are black people you know
they're only ones who are truly all
something from the government they're
really not I mean the government
government when the government does
something bad granted it sucks you know
that I don't know Jenna Mize really
anything the government does especially
when they you know discriminate or
actively um you know contribute to the
you know hardships of a particular
people especially on things such as
disgusting as race racial racial grounds
or cultural or ethnic grounds or
religious grounds
um that's dealt with something that
should be condemned but you know I
always ask people you know they say you
know government
it should help fix you know this problem
they [ __ ] up I'm like usually the
problem that they [ __ ] up originally
came from them trying to fix something
else so it's a continuous cycle of
government trying to fix his screw-ups
and then it screws up again and
eventually John's gotta say you know
what I'm good I know I'll take care of
it I'll take you from here yeah and
especially in regards to um discussion
you know done by said this is people
have their own destiny I believe people
you know can do what they want with
their own life so I always say you know
I like when people agree disagree you
know we're all individually all have our
different pursuits we all have our
different ideas of how we think the
world should work of how we think what
would contribute better to society what
would what would yield better results
for you know the future of humanity and
that's awesome that's why we have the
market you know them you know feel free
to pursue what you want and we'll see
the best ideas rise to the top yeah but
you know I always ask me we know can we
agree disagree and they always say sure
you know I don't have a problem let's
agree disagree
that's fine cool but then you know
coming down line they always advocate
for this law or this bill or support
this politician is going to actually
infringe on that conversation that we
just had and saying so it's not really
saying I agree disagree it's really
saying I disagree and you're just gonna
have to suck it up and deal with it
otherwise you're gonna go to jail for
disagreeing with my personal opinion
because I'm going to get enshrined by
law right that's that's that's
completely you know um no I forgot the
word well it's counter it's powder
everything else that you're saying
basically exactly it's contrary
antithetical to libertarianism and all
the principles of freedom and
individualism you know people always
preach individualism if you're if you're
constantly asking government to you know
pass some legislation to control other
people you don't give two shits about
individualism I'm sorry but I'll call
you out on that for being hypocrite if
you're constantly proposing that
government be the solution to humanity's
problems or society's ills you don't
care about individualism you care about
collectivism and you believe that your
ideas are what the collective would be
better off that that may be true and
maybe not but once you begin to
that was I don't have a choice anymore I
know it's not how much in this do you
think is just about the way people view
human nature because I think that a lot
of people hear things that you're saying
and of individual and all that stuff and
they they view that as selfish it's
thought of as selfish now I would view
it as you doing what's good for you is
the best thing you could do because by
doing good for yourself most likely
you'll do good for your family and
friends you'll do good for your wider
community things like that so that that
fully makes sense to me versus them
saying wow you're doing good for you
you're gonna be selfish you're gonna you
know pollute the water or whatever
except if you think about it in the
macro sense you're not going to pollute
water that you know you have to drink so
it's just really just it's just sort of
how we view human nature more than
anything else right yeah exactly and
there's um you know kind of scary vibe
towards you know selfishness and greed
you know we have green does one be a
pain on society you know people are
going to care about each other just
going to look just for each other over
the thing is the most you know the most
benefit that society has ever gained
from what I believe is the best economic
system in the world or in humanities
history cable ism the best the most
benefits and most useful application we
received from this system have come
about from greed it's come about from
people pursuing their own self-interest
doing what they want to do so they get
the result that they want to see and I
don't think that's a bad thing
you know the Baker you know who bakes
who bakes cakes you know he's doing what
he wants to do he wants to see you know
um I guess more like if it's a wedding
bakery more weddings and he wants to
contribute a so he wants to you know
pursue that and he wants to contribute
to you know getting getting paid or
maybe he just wants to increase the
devisor marriage that's fine that may be
beneficial Society and we appreciate his
service because obviously if he's
employed people are buying his product
then we appreciate it
same thing with things like um like
charity you know people don't give the
charity just because they're selfless
just know no one in the world is
selfless yeah people get the charity
because they
feel good they they have a self interest
in helping others and I think that's
beautiful that's a great thing you know
and if you have a self interest in
helping others then go ahead and pursue
that help others yeah the same sense
yeah well that's why I mean this idea of
human nature because it seems to me that
people that believe in the collective
they say well we need the state to give
people a certain amount of something
because left to their own devices people
wouldn't help the needy but I don't know
if that's actually true because plenty
of people we have those systems in place
now and plenty of people still do help
so I wonder sometimes if you pull back a
little bit of that that help that we're
giving people which we know often traps
people too if we pull that back if
people on their own because of their own
human nature which you're saying is it's
selfish in its own way
but that they might give more actually
if we didn't have the artificial peace
that the government gives you think
that's fair to say I think it's very
fair to say and it may it may be
arguable that that they may give more we
may get less because we're not be able
to steal it or print it up or you know
it no I'm just drop dead on people you
know unconsented they have to pay for
you know right now America is like 16 no
19 trillion in debt so we wouldn't have
that option I don't think that's a bad
thing right but yes I think I think
people would voluntarily contribute and
the thing is you know people always they
always envision you know charity or you
know bettering humanity from a selfless
standpoint from you know we're just
going to give people money we just want
to give welfare we're going to give them
how they we're just going to give it to
them and that's really that's that's a
great thing that's that helps sometimes
but it's really not the best thing that
helps people the best thing that helps
people humanity in general is wealth
accumulation and if you think about it
you know how am i helping a poor person
you know making minimum wage at
mcdonald's by buying a sandwich at
mcdonald's because that gives them
steady employment that gives them money
to go home and feed their family and
that gives mcdonald's money to expand
their business to and post employ more
people you know I know Trump not about
writers are scared of you know our jobs
going overseas but as
if we're contributing and accumulating
wealth and you know expanding you know I
don't see a problem I think it's really
good that we're expanding country or
expanding overseas employing people and
other third world nations who never had
the opportunity that Americans you know
take for granted a people who you know
say yeah you know this foreign aid is
nice this is little welfare here and
there is good but really what they
really want is just economic stability
really want wealth and the only way to
really give someone wealth is to UM
contribute to the market to engage in
market activities to engage against
sensual transactions for a mutually
consensual exchange benefit and I think
it's a lot that's missing a lot of
people they just don't really see the
value to their adding every time they go
out and buy a TV or every time I go out
and you know um you know buy a new cell
phone or anything like that or new
clothes they always see that as a bad
thing like I'm selfish I'm not helping
humanity I'm just doing for myself and
doing what I want to do when in reality
you're helping humanity a hell of a lot
more than the government is with your
taxes for welfare right somebody built
that phone somebody put it in a box
somebody put a sticker on it somebody
sold it to a Best Buy and somebody now
gets to go home and feed their family
you know where otherwise they wouldn't
have been they would have had to depend
on the government for you know for may
that may get misplaced it works we see a
lot would get sent to you know arms and
you know military expansions and you
know sometimes just gets corrupted and
it gets held up in bureaucracy where the
politicians extort at all whereas really
if they just had a job that's a lot
better than just hoping that they get a
little shred of what this massive amount
of money that government is just you
know wasting constantly yeah so let's
back up because you mentioned the Baker
so we have to talk about the the Baker
and the gay cake and everybody freaked
out about it because you know look I am
a liberal I say this constantly and I
really fall in what is a classical
liberal sense that I try to analyze each
thing on its own merit and and go from
there and I try to look out for the
other when I can and and I use logic and
reason okay now
this was a case where I realize I'm a
little more libertarian because now
having seen the whole the way it
unfolded in the median everything with
this was in Indiana I think it was in
Indiana you remember uh yeah believe so
I think Indiana but basically this uh
couple didn't want to bake cakes for gay
weddings the media went bonkers and
everyone said you know the government
should force them to do it blah blah
blah I would say in this case I'm a pure
libertarian I would not force a private
company to do anything they want if
anything don't bring your business there
and eventually some other Baker a block
away is going to start baking gay cakes
and then people will go there and let
let the market adjust itself I think you
would agree with that right absolutely I
mean you know this is something that
many people may not agree with but I've
made a video on it before and I still
stand by it anti-discrimination laws are
stupid
not only are they ineffective they just
they they're they're more so a cloak for
bigotry rather than a solution to
exterminate it and you know I think that
would be explain what you mean by that
because I think that's a really clever
clever phrase well yeah I mean if you
think about it like for example if I'm
gay but if a wedding Baker conservative
Christian Baker Catholic Baker decided
hey I don't want to bake gay wedding
cakes you know and you um you as a
person say that's not cool I don't want
that in my society the proper thing to
do the proper channel to take is to
acknowledge there and now as their
beliefs respect their own beliefs
and remove them from the market with
your dollars don't support their
businesses
protest them advocate that other
businesses don't condone this type of
behavior and try to get that ideology
out of the market and if you think about
it when people when people start to
realize that their pockets are hurting
they really have a really quick um you
know mental mental you know come to
Jesus so to speak exactly like is this
really worth it just believe really
worth having like you know I love you
Jesus you know I know you don't like
gays but
No damn I'm losing out a lot of money
you know because this is certainly
something right I mean Christians
precious pink and shoot [ __ ] out the
Bible all the time you know what what
they wanted acknowledged and what they
don't so I think if the people have an
incentive to no disregard something I
think that's on that they'll really
reconsider and maybe come to the
conclusion that you know what maybe they
have a point I mean all these people are
you know coming at me all people are
saying you know but I'm believing it's
wrong
maybe I should reevaluate my position
but when you do it you know at the hand
of a government force we just say hey
it's not it's not allowed you know you
can't have the idea it's illegal you
know if you do it you're gonna go to
jail you get your business shut down
whatever that not only not only is it
disrespectful and you know invalidates
property rights which is completely
unethical libertarianism and also to the
individual miss invalidating their
individual rights to hold their beliefs
in practice they're you know privately
owned probably held business as they see
fit it also just gives them a cover to
say you know what I'm not going to you
know adopt these beliefs I'm not going
to you know engage in the marketplace of
ideas I'm just going to do this because
I have to but underneath I really really
still don't like gays and now that I'm
forced to right now you really don't
like them exactly I really don't like
them I really hate the ass you know oh
you know that this ly in this leads to
more you know more division more
hostility among groups and it's not just
gays among among african-americans and
you know among african-americans and
whites among men and women you know when
people were saying you know like we had
to have women mandated or you know to
get in the draft that we had to have
know the certain amount of you know
female female politicians in office you
know people rose starting to think like
damn I really don't like this for you a
politician now because now I don't think
she got down her own merit I don't think
her ideas are being valued for what they
are I think she just there because she's
a woman and maybe she's just there
because she maybe she's there on her own
because she just thinks she's a woman
and that's really not a healthy
situation for you know social relations
among people yeah so well now you are
for government man
that all Ghostbusters movies have to be
with women right yeah yeah that that's
something that should definitely happen
I mean I'm waiting on white not gopis
Ghostbusters three already and how are
they gonna have Miley Cyrus and Taylor
Swift in there maybe even Kim Kardashian
when cayenne runs for president that's
gonna be awesome
all right so all this libertarianism
talk we got to talk Gary Johnson here
for a second because first off I should
say that Gary Johnson does not agree
with us on what we said about the the
Baker because he believes the government
should be allowed to do something so
this is a case where I think both of us
are more libertarian maybe that's not
surprising for you but when I heard it I
was surprised I think well I'm actually
more libertarian in that sense than this
guy that being said I basically like the
guy and I think he best represents the
ideals that I hold rather than Trump or
Clinton what do you think a Gary Johnson
yeah like he said I also agree not to
brag but I am more libertarian than Gary
John is a good thing to say it I'm more
libertarian did that status over there
but um Gary Johnson he's a cool guy you
know I've heard him speak I actually
voted for it was actually the first
politician I voted for in 2012 and he
may be the last politician I ever vote
for now that I'm adopting a more you
know libertarian extreme libertarian
position where I don't really see the
validity of government anymore he might
be the last though Trump is persuading
me a little bit with the memes but he's
fell off a lot but Gary Johnson he's
he's a cool guy I like what he's doing I
like that he's that he's at least brain
people to the ideas of libertarianism um
lucky like he said you know he's he's
not a perfect libertarian I think he's a
lot more left-leaning and I think his um
his running mate bill well this is also
a lot more you know left for thoughts
carryin leaning um even though he's a
Republican and surprisingly but um you
know I'd give this criticism a lot of
people saying you know Gary Johnson I'm
too pure you know I just should let the
guy do what he does at least he's
getting us you know at least basically
the whole argument of Gary Johnson right
now
centers on getting him to 50% yeah it's
he's given 15% does at least get them
into the base which I agree with you
know necessarily what kind of I'd say
this because I don't necessarily think
that Gary Johnson is the best person not
even really close to the best person who
I would want on the first next of the
base stage representing libertarianism
because of kind of is and if he's
watching this isn't you know hopefully
you take this his try but he's kind of
awkward no he got these crazy eyes
caring Zeenat Johnson and he's in these
not be not be not really principal in
his delivery libertarianism not like
senpai Ron Paul uh uh we can get her on
yeah and hopefully um totally he does
better going forward
but I do understand that I do understand
that people saying you know even if
you're not the best you know let's at
least support them you know in getting
fifty percent he's supported me getting
someone else on a debate stage besides
the same old Hillary and Trump and even
I would say even though I don't
personally believe they use the best
both versions libertarianism and I'm not
really supporting him that much in this
election just because of that but that's
not really something to say they don't
support any politicians but if you are
on the fence if you're really fed up
with crooked Hillary if you're tired of
Trump's BS baloney on how we're going to
build the ball and deport all the
illegals and make America great again
and defeat evil China if you're sick of
all that crap and you you know you're
stuck with these two horrible options
and you really just don't want even if
you're going to support Hillary or Trump
just because they're lesser two evils in
your opinion at least right now in the
polls just on papers say you support
Gary or even just on papers say you
support Jill Stein just so we can have a
diversity of ideas on this debate stage
because I think that's even more
beneficial even if you want to change
your vote at the end and really in the
end vote for Trump or Hillary at least
at least just just have a conversation
on national television to where at least
people wake up to where they can kind of
break through this mentality these are
only two options they have these are
only two options they're ever going to
have going forward see I got a I got to
stop you for a second because I want to
be very clear we're taping this so I
taped a video yesterday that's a direct
message that by the time our interview
right now will be out
have been out for a week or two maybe
three and you just laid out exactly what
I said about Gary Johnson he I said he's
not perfect he's not the greatest
debater he's not the greatest
libertarian but and Trump sucks for a
lotteries and Hillary sucks for a lot of
reasons I can understand why you might
vote for Hillary if you don't want the
wheels to come off I can understand why
you might vote for Trump if you think
social justice is at a control and but
at least get the guy to 15% for one time
so that we can just maybe have another
voice in there so I just want to be
totally clear that you just said that
not hearing what I said because I taped
yesterday and I taped it yesterday so I
hadn't heard what you said so great
minds think alike I think is my point
there exactly just anybody out there all
your fans who are kind of on the fence
who are still hoping out for Bernie join
the libertarian master race already come
on
stays up the Train I'm on the train
forget Trump train it's on the
libertarian - master race train so let's
let's talk about Ron Paul a little bit
I'm trying to get Ron Paul on the show
so if you do a hell of a cell job here
maybe I can clip this and send it to his
people would you say that he basically
is the standard bearer for what you the
role of government that you would want
absolutely Ron Paul is probably pretty
much the most philosophically consistent
politician I've ever seen and also the
most libertarian politician I've ever
seen and he does a great job in
articulating his ideas he's very
principled and he's even gone more
towards volunteerism now especially not
he's out of politics um but you know who
wouldn't you take six months they say
after your libertarian to become full
and cap oh okay that's right so how long
how long are you on the train I'm still
a classic liberal I'm just seeing it
with you guys and I get some of the I
get some of the points but this way all
the label stuff you know it's so funny I
know how much you hate labels too and
that's the whole point of attacking all
this sjw nonsense and yet at the same
time we feel we have to you have to say
well I'm an anarcho-capitalist to
describe how that's different than a
mainstream libertarian we always get
caught in all this nonsense when it's
like because it's hard to explain the
the the big stuff all the time
exactly and you know people people
always know but right now ideologues and
ideologies are really turning people off
especially ideological labels I always
tell people I adopt at that label
anarcho-capitalist libertarian 80s and
things just because I've examined these
ideas I've examined these philosophies
and they do consistently align with my
core principles that's why I adopt them
but you shouldn't feel forced to adopt
an ideological label now people who say
they don't have ideology that post us on
Twitter the other day people who say
they don't have ideologies are just
hipster [ __ ] trying to be trendy
everyone has an ideology because it's
really just a score set of ideas if you
don't have ideas then you know one
should be voting and two I don't know
how you're alive but uh everyone has
idea in ideology but you know you don't
have to don't feel compelled to adopt a
label just say it's your own self
ideology you know a ideology I am a
narrow capitalist I am libertarian but
in the end it's Telly's ideology is that
guy sees a yeah ideology and that's just
it evolves it doesn't have to be set in
stone I can change my mind I can adopt
different points of view as I see new
evidence and I think that's a lot of
people a lot of people are really
appreciative of that now rather than
trying to maintain these strict
ideological labels and concept that
they're constantly constrained to the
Phinn that's a lot of classical liberal
stuff you've given me yeah I mean
classical liberalism is pretty nice it's
pretty nice you know black people a lot
people who say they're classical
liberals don't really adopt the economic
side of classical liberalism which I
really don't
this sucks but yeah hopefully soon
enough yeah so uh wait I want to talk
about the voting thing because you've
mentioned it a couple of times that you
did vote once a Gary Johnson that you
might not vote again um so how for all
it lit for someone that's listening to
you right now that here just gets you a
hundred percent and wants tallied 20/20
for something for that person but you
won't even be 35 in uh 2032 maybe twenty
thirty to some like that but for that
person that hears what you are saying
this is I get this well if you're saying
you won't vote how else do you expect
the system to change you know people
people always ask you know
what do we do if we don't vote you know
no don't not voting you're throwing away
your bone you know you're basically
consenting to whatever happens no I'm
actually not consenting to whatever
happens because I'm not legitimizing the
corrupt system that we have by saying
I'm just gonna settle with this one
because it's gonna happen anyway I don't
really have a choice and that's really
the nature of government you don't
really have a choice in the matter
I'm just saying I'm gonna settle with it
maybe next maybe next four year going
round we'll have something better but
you know suck it up and deal with this
[ __ ] for a while
I don't really like that approach and
people always say you know especially
people who support Gary Johnson getting
him on the ticket on the base stage to
just express the ideas they know he's
not going to win they know he's not
going to UM to become the next president
the United States statistically so
really they're really just legitimizing
him because they want these ideas
expressed they see the value in the
exchange of ideas in the marketplace and
actually getting people to think about
things rather than just getting someone
elected and I think the more than voting
far more capable of voting that someone
can do rather than you know trying to
support a politician or trying to
campaign for someone or trying to you
know Trump 20 2016 or you know I'm with
her or I guess I'm with her or I'm with
it the best thing that you can do as an
individual is contribute your ideas for
tribute you know what you have to offer
to the market you know people always are
afraid of saying what they want to
believe they're afraid that you know
might get on fire it might you know they
might not be the best most person they
think that this person might say it
better they don't feel confident in
themselves look and think about if all
of your viewers not necessary all let's
say let's say 15% of your viewers you
know that's that's basically a few tens
of thousands of people and they just
went out made a YouTube channel made a
blog made some sort of atmosphere to
where they where they express their
ideas they got these ideas out there and
actually contributed to changing the
minds of other people because the thing
is I feel like you know I'm more
persuaded by having by be has changed
more so by other people who are just
standing what they believe rather than a
politician you know rather than Hillary
or Bernie your Trump I've heard these
talking points over and over
these guys ideas but I haven't heard it
the millions of people who support these
clowns share their own individual
pursuit their own individual ideas on
what they want to see change society I
think that's a much more effective
process to getting change or to enacting
change because all change that comes you
know whether it be through political
processes through the market or through
anything
it all comes from ideas it all begins at
someone had an idea and that idea was
adopted by millions I love that man
because you're not just talking [ __ ]
it's literally what you are doing with
your life yeah I'm trying to try to lead
by example I always say I want to be the
change that I want to see in the world
you know I wanted that but I want to see
a change in market I want to see
something new something innovation or
something like that I want to contribute
to that not only by just supporting
someone else who says they're going to
do it but actually getting my own voice
out there cuz the thing is I think I
don't think my voice is any less dire
but your voice is any less valuable than
Trump or Hillary's and that I think it's
more valuable because we can I can
actually trust you more cuz you don't
really have any sub gain I mean you're
doing pretty good at patreon but not be
so selfish toughest ambitions you know
like I'm gonna corrupt these guys I'm
going to just chill out to them so I can
so I can get what I want you're actually
involved in this you actually want
people to actually just think about
these things you actually want to see a
change in the world whereas these guys
they just want to seek power yeah so if
you can contribute your ideas to the
market I think that's far more
beneficial than you know supporting a
candidate just hoping for the best you
know every four years yeah so speaking
of the idea part is as someone that's
you 22 so we have 18 years between us so
there's a generational thing there I
know pretty typical I got it but you
know but there is a generational thing
there when did this idea and the offense
thing that we've touched on a little bit
and you've done all these videos on the
social justice warriors and all this
stuff when do you think it crept into
younger people because it does seem to
be a real this outrage culture younger
people being freaked out by words and
the safe spaces the triggers all that
stuff did you see it happen like when
you were 16 did you feel that that was
happy
then or has this just burst as big as it
is just in this last now it feels like
2-3 years to me where it's just gone
completely bananas exactly I mean this
is really he's really done fine it's
really confusing right now like when did
when did young people become such
[ __ ] like when did it happen right I
thought we were supposed to be the edge
lord I thought we were supposed to be
the guys who are rebelling against the
system who are trying to you know just
super independent you know I'm gonna be
my own person now we're just cuddling up
to government we're calling up to you
know our University you know professors
or you know our safe space members or
you know our tumblr tumblr friends or
whatnot and to be honest when it started
I don't really know um because I've I
was really a political for most of my
life so I really didn't get two shits
about most of this stuff I'm talking
about now but whether that happen for
you I say probably around the 17 mark um
it started off unfortunately with Alex
Jones I was a really hard
shtf [ __ ] hit the fan prepper guy I was
I was I knew the FEMA cares were about
to come I knew that all people out here
just didn't know what the [ __ ] they were
talking about they were just dumbfounded
by mainstream television and you know
not having proper water filters and the
fluoride no just contaminating their
minds and today attending is 10x10
there's still there's still a lot of
[ __ ] sheep out there you know people
you doggies the worst a lot of people
who just really don't think about things
and they just go with the flow just go
with the day we drove their life without
actually thinking critically about
anything you know especially these
really serious issues that affect all of
us but I say probably Rob I 18 19 years
old I can't get realization that you
know I just I just like thinking about
stuff I've always been creative
intellectually I think I've always liked
like writing and you know just making
things I've been handsy and crafty I'd
always just liked creating stuff and
when I found out that you know hey I
don't really have to you know you know
just tear up [ __ ] in my mom's basement
in just some blob of nonsense and just
say oh that's a cool contraption I can
actually create things in my head I can
ask the great ideas I thought that was
pretty cool and I guess that just that
just took off for me it's really fun
yeah so you must be the only youtuber in
history that their mom found out
were happy to be a youtuber because you
instead of breaking [ __ ] and painting
and whatever else you were doing down
there you were actually doing something
productive exactly exactly I didn't I
didn't have I didn't have the UM you
know really really the thing that my mom
liked when I stopped doing u2 that I
gave up I stopped slowed down on video
games because when I was um I just share
this quickly when I was probably around
I don't know what age was maybe like 14
13 um I I was really heavy on Brenda
battle san andreas mm-hmm and that
really had a huge influence on my life
for a short period of time and I
remember some day the mom would come in
and say come on to give the give the
game a break you know come do some
reading come come come you know clean
the dishes I'm like and I'm thinking
like I'm CJ in this moment of the game
I'm just like [ __ ] I just took over a
hood what the [ __ ] are you talking about
I don't have time to do dishes I'm
trying to protect bro Street and the
villages it was reckless that's the
difference between us I grew up on Super
Mario Brothers my mom would come down I
bought a baker a pizza do some plumbing
or something okay all right so you're
downstairs playing video games I used to
be a huge gamer myself I've told me but
I even worked at Electronics Boutique I
was assistant manager you may know it as
Game Stop but I was a hardcore gamer for
a long time and video games never caused
me to shoot anybody playing Super Mario
Brothers I did e magic mushrooms because
of that but besides that I never there
was no violence played Grand Theft Auto
I never punched hookers stole cars you
don't see a connection between those
things do you no no I mean I did all
those same things I ran over hookers and
I think I have a great relationship with
hookers now but you know idea you know
those are completely idiotic things and
you know people are saying you know the
video games contribute to violent video
games make people you know kill others
you know it's the same nonsense as
people saying
guns make people kill others or violent
video games or violent movies or just
portrays of violent imagery helps or
contributes to violence and also the
nonsense that people on you know the
feminist agenda pushing now or they're
saying things like you know curvy bodies
and video game characters there
you know nice butts and you know
volleyball games are you know
contributing to misogyny or internalized
sexism it all that BS you know that's
you know we never at violence or
misogyny before video games and movies
exactly it never existed in fact you
know it it's funny that I use that
argument because we're so less
misogynistic and so less you know
violent a society now that we have so
much of an higher of a you know increase
and all these violent you know or
misogynistic you want to call it areas
of media but yeah you know these things
don't don't you know change people you
know only thing that contributes to
people doing bad things is the people
themselves their individual self
interest if they just really want to do
bad things video game isn't going to you
know make them do that I can appreciate
a good drive by in Grant Abbado and not
go out and kill I love black man I can
appreciate a curvy body or or a nice you
know scene with a nice slap on the ass
in a video game and not go out and just
you know cat call women or you know just
expect every women to just walk around a
bikini and yoga pants even though that
probably would be a little nice right
and actually I'm pretty sure you they've
done studies where you can actually
prove the opposite that people are able
to get some of their aggression out by
playing video games instead of punching
people on the street or do another [ __ ]
that you probably shouldn't be doing but
let's shift over to to two more two more
things so let's talk about black lives
matter a little bit you've been pretty
critical of the movement and I think it
in line with everything else you're
saying it's sort of a call it's become a
collectivist movement so it's against a
lot of your your individualism ideals my
feeling on it is that it has morphed
into something different now where I had
sympathy for the original intentions I
think and maybe I was wrong about where
my my sympathies were but I did and now
I see it as something much different can
you just lay out what you think is that
think everybody was as been really let
down by black
I think they've really done disservice
not only to you know their movement but
also to the greater problems that
african-american community face and also
to the greater you know combatants
against police brutality which is a
major issue you know I think everybody
can sympathize with that that hey you
know over you know exactly know just
reckless use of police force or violence
you know in shootings or you know where
that the increased militarization for no
apparent reason and you know it's just I
think everybody can agree that those are
bad things and everybody once did agree
but now black lives matter has gone from
actually confronting cases of police
brutality or police misconduct to just
saying
whenever cop shoots a black person we're
gonna write it come on
I mean sometimes there are I know this
this may freak out some some super far
left people but there are black people
out there who are [ __ ] there are
black people out there who are criminals
there are black people out there who
kill other people you know people always
say you know when I criticize black on
black crime that would say hey look at
that you know what why are you
mentioning that you know that's not a
legitimate thing the the demographic
most likely to kill me as a young black
man it's other young black men
especially living in a highly populated
urban city you know the highly uhm
really dense black population and I
think I think if you tell a white
liberal dad you know is on the front
line saying you know that that black and
white crime is illegitimate it's not
worth talking about if I tell them that
hey the broke person must like at the
end of my life which you say black lives
matter another young black men so excuse
me for wanting to address these types of
these types of you know areas and trying
to find solutions to these problems
isn't that the best example of the
collectivism purse the individual is
something they're trying to look at this
group and they're saying this group is
oppressed so we must help them and and
by doing that these these liberal elites
or regressives whatever you want to call
them they actually throw the individual
you in this case someone that lives in
Atlanta they actually throw you under
the bus exactly it's like do you really
care about black lives do you really
care about helping black people or
advancing the social status or economic
status or just you know relatively say
say safety status of black black wives
are you just known as for virtue
signalling are you just knowing is
because you want to feel good because
you want to feel like you're helping I'm
helping look I walk I've marched a
parade and you know and they said all
white blue go to the back of the line to
the black lives matter conference I'm
helping I'm go to the back of the line
right you're not going [ __ ] your your
look and you look ridiculous
you look like you suffer from white
guilt and you look and you're not
actually helping solve the actual
problem that black people face which
police mentality is a problem but it
pales in comparison to the many other
problems that black people face
including the war on drugs including um
you know poor economic status you know
would that be the raising of the minimum
wage you know the increased unemployment
of young black men including the area of
fatherless homes you know all these
other things you know but I'm not blood
on let's make heart disease heart
disease
let's get by to stop eating KFC every
[ __ ] um every other meal you know
there's this or this is it know which
and I might go get some of that cuz I
just I didn't say much of hungry thing
though that sounds good I haven't had
lunch yet right
KFC it is there's actually one on the
way home for me um all right so uh final
thought I saw on on the videos that you
do normally this is your normal
background you're in a different room
right so in your normal room you got a
bunch of posters behind you got a lot of
cool stuff I hopefully people check it
out you have something for Bitcoin there
now I Bitcoin has been like a running
joke with me for like a year because I
just simply it's like when my mom asked
me the cloud and I tried to explain it
to her I feel like people try to explain
Bitcoin to me and I never know what the
hell they're explaining so finally this
weekend I signed up I got a wallet
Bitcoin wallet because somebody said I
want to send you you know half a Bitcoin
did it got it I saw some money in my
account and then literally the next day
or I think maybe was a few hours later
someone said I want to send you a full a
full Bitcoin that's about 500 bucks or
something so I have it I have this stuff
right now I think I've one and a half or
one in point seven five bitcoins
I don't know what the hell it is I don't
know what I'm doing I don't know what
the while it is explain this to me and
to the rest of America yeah
I'm not I'm not a Bitcoin connoisseur
either I'm not an expert in the field
but um you know if one if you're getting
that much Bitcoin from your audience hey
tell them to come to my channel check
out my class today like me too I could
take a Bitcoin your link is right down
below the link is right down below yeah
but um yeah exactly Bitcoin bitcoin is a
really good innovation because one is
getting us away from the you know the
the centrally managed currency system of
the Federal Reserve we just Federal
Reserve notes is getting a whit getting
us a ways giving us a basically an
alternative in the market in the means
of exchange via currency you know not
only you know I mean because you really
can't buy anything with gold
you really can't buy anything with um
with just butter no miscellaneous tools
and stuff or silver Bitcoin gives us an
option to be able to transact and be
able to engage transactions free from
this other entity that's other you know
medium that has been riddled with
corruption that has been that's you know
has lost you know I think 97 percent of
this value since since this inception
you know with inflation and you know
printing and you know the national debt
know decreasing the value of the dollar
Bitcoin freezes up from all of that and
the good thing about Bitcoin is is it's
really primed for the digital expansion
the expansion of the internet the online
sphere of the world and its really good
at in you know facilitating transactions
and actually maintaining wealth you know
across borders across barriers because
you bitcoin is really relatively
available in every country now whether
it be from America to Switzerland to
Canada to them Bob way you know it gives
people a means to where they can
actually you know leave their their
government established currency where
that whether it be doing well right now
whether it be failing or that be you
know subject to corruption and that's to
give them an opportunity to you know go
to a currency that is you know that we
all engage in that every
is a part of and that's also free from
this external corruption you know of
course we have hacks here and there
stuff but it's a really cool concept I
see so many different applications for
it going forward but right now I just
use it to buy gift cards I was gonna ask
you what am I supposed to do cuz I did a
little googling look I got buy some gift
cards some electronic equipment I mean
you can do stuff with it so basically
you're telling me don't cash out just
yet hang on to it and let's see what
happens
not yet not yet I mean we've seen
bitcoins a time right now I think it
said like I think two hundred and sixty
dollars something that two hundred
eighty ninety I mean we seen bitcoins
that hides of a thousand twelve hundred
dollars so definitely don't cash out I
mean if you I do it because I'll be
hurting for cash and you know I just
know I see something I need a bay and I
just like I'll use my Bitcoin return my
credit card right but but I'm here if
you're in it in it for the long haul you
have enough in in you know your personal
savings you have enough to invest and
make it an investment
definitely don't cash out right now
definitely maintain it for the long haul
and make sure it's secure make sure you
have it in a secure location because I
know a lot of areas have been getting
hacked lately and having the per coin
stolen so just keep up with that and
yeah in the future you know you might
have you might start off with you know
four hundred five dollars in Bitcoin ten
years two years from now it might be you
know worth ten thousand so it was good
to maintain it's a good thing to hold up
it's a good you know medium if you don't
want to invest in gold to just have like
for it to hit the fan scenario if
anything happens the economy collapses
and we're all you know and mark the law
and stuff you just want to get some
groceries and you can't do something
with your with your hundred dollar bill
which is now worth to duck two bucks
bitcoin is a good alternative to have
yeah you like how you became my
financial adviser by the end of this
thing yeah yeah that's a I think is cool
you know people always say rifle video
they say oh this guy's so articulate be
so brilliant you know I think they do
say that because I'm black now this
articulate black guy
uh but I appreciate nonetheless but hey
if anyone was to hire me in the
financial advisor
gawky you know proper gains but I'm up
for it I like that you even gave your
disclaimer right up front
dude it was a pleasure talking to you
I'm a big fan of what you do and the
link to your channel is right down below
but it's youtube.com slash that guy T
and I hope next time we get to do this
we'll have some KFC in person how about
that awesome you're going to get called
a racist for saying that you know that
right you do realize the conversation
we're having right now you just sold a
black guy we're going to have KFC for
you all right no wait how can I fix that
now how do we get out of this properly
Oh move it back man just accept it
embrace it and hopefully we'll just get
rid of the craziness to where people
don't get offended by the [ __ ]
[Music]
you